So glad to have you all here
i'm not really allowed to share anything
so
i'm going to hand it over to the great
matt reeves somewhere around here
your heart starts pumping interacting
with the passionate fan base
ready okay let's go
the batmobile is no joke you are
so good looking it's a completely
different experience
i'm dropping the mic
dc fandom explore the multiverse free
for everyone 24 hours only all fans
welcome september 12th only at dc
fandom.com
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie
this is going to be my new dc
fandom
part 2 trailer video that's right there
is a part 2 there's going to be a second
night with a bunch more footage and
trailers that they'll drop there's also
some new batman some new justice league
snyder cut footage in there we'll break
down
so if you're new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos of
course i'll do
trailer videos for all the new stuff
that they release it's happening
september 12th so it's not that far
off we'll do a new amazon giveaway too
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and let me know what your
favorite
trailer from the last dc fandom was but
because i've been getting so many
messages about robert pattinson for the
past day or so i'll just address that
first before i talk about dc fandom
stuff everybody wants to know what's
happening with the batman movie
so they started filming the batman movie
again just a little while ago just
very briefly and had to shut down right
away because one of the key
cast members got the virus warner
brothers was pretty open about it but
they didn't reveal all the details they
just said that one of the cast members
got it and they had to shut down
production temporarily
right after that happened though a bunch
of insiders in the hollywood trades like
hollywood reporter
deadline variety were all reporting that
yeah that cast member that was robert
pattinson that got the virus
so naturally everyone started freaking
out the way you would expect but i'm
sure he'll probably be fine in a couple
weeks yes it is very serious you need to
be careful about that
but he is the star of a billion dollar
franchise
they're going to give him the world's
best treatment possible for the next
couple of weeks here's the thing though
they didn't actually stop
filming the movie though they're still
making the movie right now
what the trades are reporting is that
they're just filming everything that
they can
where they don't need robert pattinson
himself to be on screen so things that
they can use as body double for
the really big action scenes the fight
scenes all the stunt work
him driving around in the batmobile then
filming scenes with the other actors
like the villains like catwoman penguin
riddler
so there's still a lot of stuff that
they can do without the need for robert
pattinson for the next couple of weeks
so they're just moving a lot of scenes
around right now
in production while robert pattinson
climbs out of that metaphorical torture
pit
really good example of something similar
happening is actually with the rock and
his family
black adam in the dc universe he
actually said that his entire family got
the virus and he actually looked pretty
solid when he was talking about it
but he is the rock he's just that
hardcore so obviously it's going to be a
little bit worse for regular people
but either way do not worry they have a
plan this is a billion dollar franchise
of course they have contingencies and
ways of working around stuff like this
number four though during the next dc
fandom event talking about the actual
event there'll be more movie stuff going
on but the difference is
is the last time they just had that one
channel on the website that they ran
like a virtual comic con hall h
presentation
with them doing movie panels one at a
time the big thing with this second
event on september 12th
is that they'll be way more panels and
trailers and most of them will be video
on demand meaning depending on which
section of the website you go to and
there will be multiple sections
you can just watch whatever you want
without having to wait but talking about
some of that new justice league snyder
cut footage you get a much better look
at some of the key scenes that will be
different from the theatrical cut
they start with them of that scene
filming the justice league versus
superman fight right after he's been
resurrected his resurrection in the
snyder cut will also be
totally different from the version in
the theatrical cut so it's not just the
color grading that looks different or
the lighting which is obviously very
noticeable in the snyder cut trailer
that they released a couple weeks ago
you can see that this is meant to happen
at night
and it goes on for much longer than the
version in the fight the theatrical cut
the way zack snyder explains it is that
when he was still on the movie before he
had to leave
warner brothers also told him that the
mandate was he had to cut the film down
to under two hours or right at two hours
and he actually thought that they were
joking because the snyder cut itself is
going to be over four hours long
that's why pretty much all the scenes
will be longer but there'll also be a
lot of subplots and story lines that
were just taken out wholesale
this is just another version of that
scene from them on the back of batman's
jet on their way to fight steppenwolf
this is another new scene of superman
after he's gone back to the kent farm
looking out one of the windows so it
sounds like there's going to be
way more scenes of superman with lois
lane there's just a whole lot more
superman in the snyder cut in general
they almost completely cut him out of
the theatrical cut because they deemed
his story
too dark and a lot of the other scenes
with him were part of other subplots
that got cut so tangentially he also got
cut out of those parts of the movie so
you wind up with very little superman
they really just wanted to skip to the
end where he came back and joined the
justice league
we've all seen some of the superman
black suit footage and in the snyder cut
trailer from a few weeks ago there's
also a new scene of him in the black
suit fighting steppenwolf
and wearing it in the lineup scene at
the end before they board batman's jet
to go back
there was that fascinating story that
zack snyder explained about the funny
way that they
accomplished the black suit in the movie
because if you watch the trailer footage
at the beginning of this of them
actually filming this scene of the jet
rising up and them getting ready to go
back
you notice that henry cavill is wearing
the classic suit
so the way zack snyder said that they
fixed that and created the black suit
was effectively photoshopping the blue
suit black in post-production
now they didn't actually use photoshop
they use much more complex software i'm
just using that as shorthand
but zack snyder wanted to have a way to
make it black really quick
before they released the movie if he
would have been able to convince the
studio to say yes to it
now obviously he can do whatever he
wants to with it which is why it's black
during the trailer because it's going to
be the way it is during the actual movie
number three most of the new aquaman
scenes here or when we see batman first
meeting him in the movie there's
actually a bunch of that in this trailer
this is from the steppenwolf fight at
the end of the movie this is wonder
woman scene from the superman fight with
her getting ready to get head butted by
him
this scene you'll also recognize from
that recent trailer that zack snyder
dropped a couple months ago of wonder
woman learning about darkseid in the
greek temple looking at all the
different paintings of the dark side war
from thousands of years ago
the actual painting behind zack snyder
looks like it just depicts the amazons
the atlanteans and the humans all
arriving
at the battlefield this is just more of
that scene of them deciding what to do
with the mother box
this is them filming the scene with
superman arriving at the bat cave to
meet alfred before joining the justice
league at the end of the movie
and then this is more of the steppenwolf
scene arriving via boom 2 to take the
amazon's mother box
most of that was all in that trailer
this last scene of him turning on the
bat signal seems like it's the one from
the end of the movie when gordon turns
it on
in that big montage of all the different
characters but just to be clear
the ending of the snyder cut will be
very very different from the ending of
the theatrical cut so all that might
wind up changing
i've already done a couple videos about
the supposed green lantern post credit
scenes that zack snyder had intended to
do that we might see during the snyder
cut but he hasn't really given any of
that away yet he hasn't given any big
spoilers about green lantern
number two though more wonder woman 1984
obviously that's dc's next big movie
it's still scheduled to come out october
2nd and that's
under a month as far as they've said
that date isn't going to change
even though a lot of theaters are barely
reopening in some of the major cities
they dropped what they were calling the
final wonder woman 1984 trailer with
cheetah a couple weeks ago at that last
big dc fandom event
there will be more footage though that's
just the way it works of course i'll do
more trailer videos when they release
new stuff
in number one right now there's not a
ton more batman footage for them to show
off there might be a couple other things
for the characters like catwoman penguin
riddler
originally matt reeves was actually
going to drop a trailer for it in
december at brazil comic con
that might still wind up happening even
though the actual convention itself
might wind up being cancelled if it
hasn't already
they might just wind up dropping more
footage in december also really big
reminder about the batman long halloween
movie that they're releasing next year
it's actually going to be two parts so
it'll be much bigger and much more
accurate to the comic book long
halloween story
the first part is supposed to come out
in the summer and part two is supposed
to come around the same time that the
batman movie with robert pattinson is
being released
so there will be a lot of batman related
stuff happening next year if you're a
huge batman fan
of course i'll do videos for all the dc
fandom trailers that they release in a
couple weeks as long as you have alerts
enabled for my channel you should see
those when i post them
everyone click here for my batman
trailer video with all the court of owls
easter eggs
and click here for the boys season 2
episode 1 video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!